hello everyone
welcome back this is gamespot live and
i'm richie today we are going to be
playing the new
call of duty zombies map malware der
toten
i'm seeing some some buzz in the chat
this isn't uh this isn't kino daretone
it's not a remake of any old classic
maps it's a new map
uh and i think you'll like it so let's
get right into it
how we doing today how's everyone doing
all right let me switch over to the game
mode here
there we go all right cool
okay um so i'm just gonna jump right in
i'll do a little
solo mode here to show you guys around
it's a fun
city map that's in berlin
yes i am live now hey josh welcome
welcome
all right so there's a
there's a lot of things so far and the
easter egg was just unlocked i doubt i'm
gonna
like find the big easter egg in this
stream but
there's still a lot to explore in this
map i want to show you guys around
and uh maybe
try out the new wonder weapon i'm trying
to get that i haven't got it yet
find the omega traitor valentina the
undead army must be stopped
or your pilot pays the ultimate price
okay so there's also a little more story
also you saw colonel
good old kravchenko he's got our raptor
one pilot
from um you know he's our he's our
regular pilot
uh he was captured and now we have to
work for krav chinko to get him back
basically
why am i shooting
so this map is super moody super rainy
it's really nice i played
quite a lot last night so i can practice
for the stream
but like i said there's no easter egg
yet so i mean there is now there wasn't
yesterday night
i'm hardly surprised valentina is a
double agent
though her father being in charge of
project devastation
oh boy that's a doozy
she is the daughter of a nazi scientist
and believes she is completing his
mission
she is not a doozy she's delusional
restore the power to this district
you won't find her in the dark hmm you
know they change up some of the
characters sometimes that's the first
time i've seen
peck so far so he's back and he's
rocking an eye patch
does he think he is weaver by the way i
wanted to download the weaver bundle
for chat for stream but um he's not
available yet
hey chat hello from brazil
josh smith says it looks odd seeing the
hell bars above the zombies yeah you can
turn that off but i
kind of like it for the higher rounds
when they're uh when they're like bullet
sponges it really helps
okay here i am stabbing away and i don't
even
you know there we go
so the first uh order of business
business as always excuse me
i'm sick uh get the power on so i got to
turn the power on
and uh these new maps in cold war are
always so nice they got these little
markers these little waypoints that
basically tell you how to do everything
excuse me
hopefully we'll find the box along the
way yesterday was right here for me but
today
oh and mule kick was added so there were
a few things
a new wonder weapon a new
new um piece of tactical gear which is
like the gersh device it kind of it
returns
and um a new helper forgot his name he's
like a robot
one of those crash chest dummies uh you
gotta
give him his battery and give him some
parts to build him and then he'll help
stay down no i don't know anything about
the actual easter egg
yet um all i know is that uh it deals
with uh
valentina though the commander lady from
firebase z if you finish the firebase z
easter egg
uh she's that lady that uh that takes
peck back and
uh she's mean to him she's yeah she's
not good people but now she's like the
boss of
this map
give me back phd flopper ah
i was playing some old zombies the other
day you can't even do that you can't i
mean because now you slide
you can't you don't dolphin dive anymore
so couldn't that couldn't work here
yeah it was a fun perk phd it was like
one of the last ones i would buy because
i don't really dolphin die that much
okay let's get the power on and i want
to show you guys around i'm probably
moving too fast but
uh a bigger area is here like over there
we'll get to that later that's
weird hey chat
check it out if you guys played any cold
war zombies
you might recognize that phone booth
from the very first cut scene where
samantha max's calls weaver
check it out this was added too it kind
of reminds me of war zone except it's
like a death train
watch the tracks after surviving so much
getting hit by a train would be a pity
it would check it out you'll kick his
back
although people want to double tap
that's okay
how am i liking the map so far so far i
really do like it i can't wait to get
the easter egg going
i uh sometimes i try to follow find the
easter egg on my own like i found
most of it on firebase z and i was like
cool you know but then i got stuck i
usually get stuck
trying to find the easter egg so i
follow a guide even then it's fun
i like getting the trophy and
uh seeing more of the story but the map
itself so far is really nice
it's a lot like this is the underground
part it's really cool there's a lot of
details
i didn't know requiem was investing in
robotics that's our friend and we'll
help him out later he needs a battery
and a set of hands to work
excuse me
let's get the power on and i'm in the
wrong room for that
let me know i've been really the m16 is
really
trendy right now so i gave it a shot and
it's really good for higher rounds like
they weren't kidding
getting whacked okay wasn't there a
repel line okay it's not open yet
i'm waiting here getting beat up for
nothing i got to go find the other
entrance to get to the power room
yeah look at this
that rumbling scared the crap out of me
but it's just the train above me
really you screwed up the easiest task
you'll have
all day that fuse box will need new
fuses better get looking
audio is pretty low on voice okay thank
you turn up just
a smidge this thing is pretty sensitive
uh i also kind of had just
talked kind of low i'm not really let me
know how it is now
if that changed anything okay
so i turned the switch on it's a classic
switch to get the power on but the fuses
are dead so i gotta find fuses
and the bad guys have all the fuses so
here we go
yikes there we
wouldn't have go searched the tempest
but i guess that's why you're the
professional
heck needs to go away i don't miss this
guy i wonder what happened to his eye
well
did that happen in the firebase c end
cut scene
the valentina mess with his eye
[Music]
there's a lot going on here
okay i forget where i get the other fuse
um oh here the way marker
see this map is so nice i just got to go
there
and then um the other fuse
will be i think another bad guy's
holding it
what's up chad buruto's dad back in the
chat
good to see you friend
[Music]
voice sounds good okay thanks guys i
appreciate that
uh the mic yeah it's pretty close
whatever i appreciate your help
here we go okay another tempest has got
the second fuse
yo lay off there we go
okay i'm getting him beat up by like the
two remaining zombies
can't wait to get the power on
bars
yeah oh if you guys really i mean the
the health bars you'll get
i hope you get used to it because they
they helped me in the later rounds i was
telling chat earlier uh it is weird
to see health bars over zombies and kind
of like is that necessary but
in the later rounds it really helps so i
keep them on
project end station okay
that is where you will find valentina
great
my gun gun first then a little armor
later
okay perfect
all right imagine going down before
round 10 it's happened but yeah try not
to do that
of course especially for stream got my
you know i'm in sweaty mode right now
okay it's this little seance here these
are regular zombies but they're
controlled by this dude
i have to take him down there we go
starting now you know if i had good aim
this wouldn't be a problem
get away from me he's actually not that
hard
in the early rounds obviously but that's
what he does he controls everyone
and freaks me out a little but now i can
pack a punch this thing
right over here
is remember that call of duty i think it
was black ops 1 map
about the base on the berlin wall
pretty cool it's just like this um if
you're seen by the spotlights the
turrets will shoot you
but here there's little piles of debris
you can look through and
pick up bullets and stuff i don't think
they regenerate though so i'm going to
[Music]
be careful
i should not have to tell you this yeah
yeah
okay back here for 2 000 bucks
is how i can well i can progress through
and go underground but i like using this
hill better so
i'm gonna save some money or uh earn
some money here and then
go through and try to see if i can get
the parts for the robot i haven't done
that yet
i also want to get perks
and try the new wonder weapon because um
apparently it's really cool i haven't
had my hands on it yet
you can get it from the box or you can
um get it from like a safe
uh i need rain rot to do that
just wrangling him up here
why don't you just all just walk into
this oh it's already down
whatever
look at all this stuff
and still step oh yeah i can stab until
level 10 i think for a one hit kill
okay i have enough here to actually i'm
gonna um
rain rot or my gun
it kind of stinks how they they seem to
limit you like if you want
to build the little robot that helps you
you need brain rot and if you
if you want to get the wonder weapon
like for free without using the box you
need brain rot
josh says hey richie which is this map
uh
i don't think it's it's not any old maps
mixed together
actually this is um taken from the
berlin mission
from the call of duty cold war game
uh parts of that map were used but it's
not a mix of any old maps and the map is
pretty big there's
it's like there's a street area that's
kind of like this that's small
but then there's a lot of stuff
underground i haven't unlocked most of
the doors yet
so you'll see if i you know if i don't
die here i want to show you as much as i
can
right now i'm just trying to get some
money here crap
you guys are tearing it up
i upgraded to rain rot level 5 recently
and it
really helps they don't stand a chance
against me
no no they don't okay what's that
stay down cause requiem ever encountered
the problem
we didn't try to destroy so for those of
you just tuning in that was kravchenko
the story of me being in this map is uh
kravchenko has our pilot raptor one
and he's like hey you work for us and
we'll give you raptor one back
but if not we're gonna kill him so
that's our mission
um let's see here what am i doing oh
yeah i wanted a
perk so i want i want deadshot daiquiri
that's usually what i get first because
i have terrible aim uh and it's a free
aimbot look there's mule kick
the returning perk that gives you a
third gun
i got lucky there i knew i just had bad
aim so deadshot decorates the way to go
and i also want to try to get the wonder
weapon i haven't got that yet
yikes have you guys played do you guys
play um
most of the new call of duty are the uh
the new or cold war zombies let me know
in the chat i mean
you're here and i hope you're enjoying
yourself uh but
you know trying to get a sense of where
you guys are at
all caught up on the story the stories
there are
like four easter eggs like two in
outbreak and then one in firebase z and
one and d machina like are you guys all
caught up
i kind of am i did two of the easter
eggs and
i got so close to doing one of the
outbreak easter eggs but i just i died
of
the final boss sad
okay let's make some money back here
again of course it's a great place to
make money but
i want some um shotgun so i can uh
you know what let's see if i can go to
that
you guys saw the trailer i keep
mentioning this robot he basically looks
like
a crash test dummy and he helps you out
but you have to like build him
so you know what i need a battery first
okay this game is just wanting me to
chill out so i'm gonna chill and kill
some zombies and show you guys around he
kind of looks like this guy
but it's not that
you didn't like how they made origins
harder they did
i mean i played the origins pack and i
really liked it but i don't remember it
being
oh well not a bad thing i guess level
10.
i usually keep up with zombies story on
youtube
learn how to do these easter eggs yeah
uh the only one i really the only easter
egg i really tried myself was firebasey
and i got pretty far but
uh not far enough here's the robot who
you need a battery for his head
his arms are his hands and his hands i
know where they are but i have to
um i need brain rot first
i mean uh not brain
he is
i'm used to seeing these guys outside of
outbreak
oh he dropped his he dropped the um
oh what did he drop i forgot let's go
pick it up
he drops a part of the knicks
battery i got the intel instead leave it
alone
that double points they give you double
points at the worst time in this game i
swear what are you going to do with a
battery
what was a crazy soul that going to do
with the battery i can extract you as
necessary though
you can still get uh an extraction not
from raptor one
obviously but they're like they have to
work that in somehow they're like you
better not but
you can extract if you want to
yeah from the crazy so so i just got the
battery uh
what's that i heard the
reaper dude i forget his name already
all right before i do
anything else i need dead shot dapper i
don't have any perks right now what
am i doing
okay i haven't even opened all the doors
yet okay this is just another way to get
out to the train tracks there's mule
kick over here
i forget where deadshot is ah go away
all right fine don't go away but there's
no zombies here to control
oh you can reroute these guys cool
good to have you on my side there
reaper
okay uh let's see if i remember correct
the uh i might just pick up some other
perks if i can't find a shot first uh
here's jug which we need
of course
yeah if you guys remember uh the cold
war map
uh and the mission here you meet that
lady or intel adler
meets what's her name right here in this
cafe
here like evading the guards pretty cool
you guys enjoyed the old war campaign
i did more than i thought
they're really like drawing his
character out he's in obviously he's in
black ops one but then
he gets killed in black ops 2 and this
takes place in between those games so
they're like they're really using them
again
oh i'm almost out of bullets this isn't
cool
all this stuff behind
okay well good at least i got these
these two perks that i have are like
some staple if i had stamina up i'd have
like
a classic trio you know
move this mouse out of the way so is it
just like
yeah i thought this looked like town
from black ops 2
also like uh you know part of the
transit map
um like that little intersection does
look like it
uh that's funny that we both thought
that but uh the rest of the map
i think looks pretty cool i like this
underground area like i said it's
written straight from the
campaign mode uh not all of it but
yo i need another gun i need to find the
box i'm just kind of
not doing much here let's see okay i
have enough to try the box hopefully we
can get the wonder weapon
where's the box i'm gonna look to the
skies for the box okay
almost out of bullets any any backup gun
would be nice at this point
okay yeah right here like um
no i think this this corner yeah it kind
of looks like town you know
like from black ops 2 you're right
this box go up i have to go down
oh the death train is here oh it just
passed
great
i was looking to rebuild things if i can
oh man i can't look up at the sky
anymore because
i'm good for the box hey come on
right in my way
hmm
okay i don't want to stay here for long
because i want ammo and i will come back
down there because they drop a lot of
stuff when you use the
um oh what is it called the that death
vine thing that i just used
oh the box nope i'm going in circles
y'all
okay um maybe it is
outside i'm gonna try above ground this
time
ayuka says in my opinion this map is
beautiful i hope
i hope i said your name is it on the
roof there is a
repel line to go to the roof so i'm
going to try that now
yeah i think this map is pretty nice too
where is that rope isn't that a repel
rope
maybe i should focus on not getting
killed huh now i'm completely out of
bullets
wait the m16 is in that tent i can buy
more bullets
oh look i have to zip across okay
take care of these guys
okay they drop a lot of stuff this is
great
one thing i noticed is that uh this game
oh wow look at that
um i get more fire sales than before
yeah i gotta hit the roof
um see
this building i already forget how i'm
already like i mean granted this map is
brand new so bear with me but i'm like
here we go look at that
that's your name that's how you say i
hope again i just said it right
well thanks for being here
okay where is that there's a few here's
one
awesome is not open
now it is i had to pay for it okay
oh i like this area yesterday i was
hanging out here for a long time
i mean i'll take it but fine
this is going to be too crazy i need to
get out of here
i'm going to thin out the crowd and then
come back because
i'll probably die right there never got
a max ammo
or get shot daiquiri i'm probably doing
you guys
the classic uh classically trained
zombies so i'm just gonna
herd them like this for a while and then
uh maybe for a grenade oh man
this dude is back
it's still gonna help that much well
actually
i missed black ops 2.
i do too they're they're bringing a lot
of black ops 2
multiplayer maps to cold war which makes
me think they're which makes me think
they're never gonna remake the black ops
series like stand alone
which is okay i guess i can still play
black ops 2
um you know may not be the same as it
once was the servers are different
like cheating yeah me as an incredibly
nostalgic person
i miss black ops 2 as well i missed the
times i had the black ops
okay i'm gonna try for the box again
y'all can go to hell
see ya
i capture footage for things you know
for work
and i had to play mob i like the ak-47
video
it was fun dude i missed that
gary i didn't play so much like the
second half of black ops 2 i don't
remember as much as uh
like you know i guess the first half i
gotta kill this green reaper guy
giving me the smoke i have double points
though
thank you
oh i picked up little boxes of it okay
oh i do like the mp5 bullfrog has more
well but this is damaged tier three i'm
gonna pick this back up
okay i'm gonna try the box one more time
and then go get some more perks
if they are ah fine okay okay
i like this characters
didn't open that yet holy crap
ayaka says i can't wait to play this
later yeah get the uh get the download
going
hopefully your ps4 or five is in sleep
or your xbox i forget actually i don't
think xbox can do the whole sleep
but anyway i hope i get to play this
later
i'm just building up some more points
here
i need uh i still want to show you guys
the wonder weapon and the new helper
robot
i think i can get started
all right i'll try the box one more time
and then leave
this area
oh um so for the box nowadays you can
um
so for the mystery box yeah you can pick
the gun from the box
drop it on the ground and swap it for
another one if you want
um
if you know you're just willing to waste
money like i was
holy crap
oh i made a big circle that's the issue
here
i have any more of these yes i do
crap
can't even
okay generator here
i think that was beeping like that
yesterday when i tried to play
yeah i got the teddy bear or the bunny
now there it is
they have no place in our future okay so
you know that music it's time for dogs
except it's not dogs anymore they have
like these weird red crystal guys
i'll show you they're they make
terrifying noises
they blow up just like dogs
just pick that up actually thank
goodness i'll get a max ammo after this
oh i had one bullet left in there
excellent okay i will not be using the x
fill window
i am uh try the box
oh it's underground i was like what the
hell
don't forget you can vault over steps
thank you chad who's that said jones
i don't want to art
oh maybe i can level up this thing
finally
oh man right now dude
run over by the train
look at that the whole time it's right
here
i'll take that watch me go into complete
cheater mode with this
chuck deferent whatever man i love it
these zombies
kick your ass and if you don't have this
he'll die
look at that look at all those box
locations and i need to run faster
man box over the hill
seven seconds i'm not gonna make a
mystery box
this one back here that was the worst
fire sale thanks to me ever oh there was
one right there
okay no biggie i got deadshot daggery i
have brain rot i should really try to go
get
the robot started um i forget which
hotel room epic continue the fight
yeah yeah oh there's a wonderful machine
i'm stepped in this room yet y'all need
to leave me alone
where'd he go all right
i like the sounds this guy makes he's
always like simply devil or something
come on what the don't run for me
i run from you okay
that's not a real door um which i'm
looking for the hotel room that has the
special boarded up windows where you can
get
it kind of looks like this
it says it on the top left of the screen
like it says yeah 305 thank you chat um
i just forget like
i went down uh i can't go back up either
okay
uh hotel room 305 is where i need to go
i think it's in the beginning of the map
hopefully this
this area it's like one of these
buildings you know um
but in that building is where you can um
get the parts you need for the robot the
hands specifically
i love brain i slept on brain rock
forever dude i didn't use it until um
uh i don't know a few weeks ago i
finally gave it a shot and i was like
wow
uh fully upgraded rain rot
oh i think i'm close okay
oh i needed a brain rock guy for this
next part
yeah is it this no this is 301. chat was
telling me 305.
yeah this room but it's going to get
crowded here i'm screwed
i might do a big loop around
great i heard that bad guy
i like how you can shoot one-handed get
away
needs to open this because there are
hands around that dude's neck
yeah dukes
come on i gotta make one of those
well i ran them all through this trap so
i knew this corner would be hot okay
ah they're too far to kill anyone if i
kill someone i get revived but
i have no time for that oh i lost
deadshot
yes can't open it up
oh no keep opening this oh you opened it
okay so i got the hands
those must belong to that robot in the
safe house it seems
he's uh good with his hands okay
okay just stop talking and i know how to
get that but that's another step
in that safe is the wonder weapon but
i'm still just gonna try to get the
wonder weapon from the box
um i have to
because i have to i need the robot alive
and built
first um so that i can get
a blacklight which shows you the code
to that safe so it's a long story i try
to
haven't done it yet either so i also
need to buy a um
self a lot because i keep going down i
jumped in that corner
okay they can finally update my
gun there we go level two
i'm back in this hotel of course when i
don't want to be in this hotel
like oh yeah i'll find my way here
tango removed
you see yeah i need deadshot yesterday
go down maybe it was downstairs
somewhere
okay wish me luck guys i have the
battery and the hands so now i can
activate the robot but first i'm just
like i really want
headshot daiquiri before i do anything
there's jug thank goodness i still have
that
can i do level three already no i can't
get away oh here we go and go downstairs
here
[Applause]
there's a mule kick these things keep
showing up everywhere it's
gotta be part of the easter egg easter
egg unlocked at
10 o'clock it's morning
i should use the map more
that room that i was just in of course
is where i can activate the robot
so as you can see i'm very a scatter
brained zombies player but
it's not dead yet
i'm taking them down
there we go
where was it i need like i wish you know
um like on
outbreak i wish i could have a map of
this but i can't i don't have one
no no map
the little mini map wow this is funny
three of them oh
here we go i know i need ammo
i have used these all too often yeah
yeah rivas
standard issue does the job box 10 bucks
okay the dmr is cool but it's not the
best for zombies
oh ir oh god i lost the box
oh goodness
damn dude of course i picked up i
accidentally picked up the worst guns at
that fire sale
now the sale is over whatever works
okay well at least i tried that time
last time i couldn't even get to the box
because i goofed up
now my first goal
you'll kick hey i haven't haven't bought
that yet
might as well
forgot it shoots people around you
that was worth it nice of you to share
that
there's a tent around here that sells
the m16 i can just buy emma off the wall
or one of these little
uh you know those little green boxes
here's one
okay great
i got lucky with that shot as you can
tell i'm not a crack shot
i'm
on my own i love
oh that blew up in my face
there we go you know this guy can
finally wake up
waiting for something to do cool they
don't go aggro on you
murdered your friend i'm sure you'll be
fine
shut up
okay so you control him klaus is here
he's ready to help
control him with these um little yellow
boxes i think
yeah he's currently deployed that's how
you bring him back when he goes away
it costs like 2 000 bucks to bring him
back
klaus best boy
that dude ran into the wall and killed
himself oh klaus is here okay
man i love this already
i'll just let clouds do all the work and
i'll get the max ammo
look at them sharp shooter not afraid of
the train or anything
while he's doing that actually i might
go look for a deadshot decorate because
god i need it
i think there are little um might as
well just do this
uh there are little breaker panels that
he controls
hey the real box
i'll take that fire rate over something
sub about it
um so he said there's something nearby
that's cool i haven't really worked with
klaus yet
you guys are seeing the first time i
actually have been able to
okay i screwed up royally
good thing i have those other perks here
it is
ah these things no not those things some
a little breaker panels control klaus
and like he opens stuff
dude i thought i picked up the other gun
that's not the dmr what is this
oh i picked up the ppsh
oh no my m16 is on the ground somewhere
wow i don't think i've ever done that
stupid
oh well this is still alive what's up
now let's
see where the mystery box is
and just hope that my m16 is still on
the ground
oh goodness gracious
[Applause]
this is the dumbest thing i've done in a
while
i keep going in this room i forget where
the box is is it up here
oh my god guys that that gun's probably
going to go eraser
you need to go away now look at this
weak ass gun it can't do anything
i've really screwed up
klaus
[Applause]
okay i went there so i'm gonna try this
side
i cannot believe i did that i've been
here too
this is like a maze dude one day i will
finally get to know the layout of this
map but right now i'm
screwed up royalty guys
okay the box is over there that's good
that's a good indicator i have to go
underground but on this side
come on how long
will i be streaming for um until
11 30 a.m pacific time
so you know like 45 minutes something
like that
no it's not on the ground i screwed up
big time guys my m16 is gone
i'll take
wait
oh yeah there's no self-revive uh i have
to kill someone to get back up
yeah a better tomorrow says uh you have
a mini map for a reason
okay goodness gracious i survived that
somehow i didn't deserve to
cool all right we're back on track baby
i need jug i need i need to catch up
with all the good stuff
actually
wow this dude needs to kill more people
faster
i love that he's on my side though
maybe the supplies here in these little
piles
to do that though good thing it didn't
despawn
yeah oh my god i seriously i was like
well that's the end of this life i was
gonna have to start over again
which is fine i'm gonna be streaming for
a little bit here but um
i didn't want to you know i made i made
some progress we unlocked klaus
okay i need armor i need um
the rest of my perks back stamina up
i guess i'm not in really a rush so i
don't need that first i'm trying to
prioritize
what rips
i'm taking them down i want class back
so i can get the um
what's it called the blacklight to get
the no i don't think i want to do it
brandon hernandez what's up man long
time long time no see
okay uh perks
perks what am i doing i'm just sitting
around
i still i still hmm i still don't know
what those are
i would like some speed cola i'm gonna
do that i think that's
up here actually yeah
what the hell it's not working why is it
oh i have it i'm an idiot i was like why
isn't it working
um okay that's the only perk i had left
actually
speed cola when i when i came back to
life
his class is he asleep like what he goes
to
oh
i'm getting out of here now oh no
oh well all right guys let me know
what um what gun you want to see me use
next i don't think the m16 is good but
the burst delay
i'm just such a bad shot you know might
try the full auto maybe the new
maybe the new smg are you guys
interested to see i heard it's uh
making waves in warzone i've heard i
heard it's got the fastest time to kill
a war zone
oh my god jack you're right jack graham
in the chat says you had a mule kick
you had three guns i didn't drop any gun
boy i got myself killed for nothing
first time i use mule kick and i use it
wrong or i don't use it
hey but i got some crystals let me see
if i can um
update mule kick or whatever
um let's see here skills
go to the perks yeah i'm such a
dork i had three guns yeah
oh my god okay let's see here slow down
okay so this this perk is cool so
your your your backup weapons will
refill ammo from stock
if i uh do this and then
25 chance to keep non-retrievable
equipment when used so cool if i throw a
monkey bomb
i might not even have to use it it'll
probably still be in my stock if i uh
have this equipped great great wow i
feel pretty silly for
letting mule kick of all things get the
best of me so dumb
but okay that's okay we've we've moved
past that
um is this a free update yeah if you
have call of duty cold war it's so
it's a free free dlc um
i got down to lost my perk yeah you guys
are reviewing my play-by-play uh
we should pause it and do yellow circles
like here's exactly where he [ __ ] up
we got some intel a little bit
uh klaus i barely got to use them
i haven't got to play it how is now
angry raccoon you are just in time i
died and i'm gonna play some more
um but i think i might see
you can earn i like to earn my weapons
um so let's see here
i like to you know earn them in the in
game so but i have to kill
50 tempests after they transform two
seconds after they
teleport that's gonna take forever so i
got some
pod points i think i think i'm just
gonna
uh pick it up yeah i'm gonna buy this
it comes with other stuff too sweet
god jeez well
uh i will let's pick this up
thanks jack that's that's really sweet i
mean you know
not a super mlg gamer i died but uh you
guys have you guys have been really nice
uh i'm playing solo also i like playing
solo
um but you know gets me killed i guess
okay let's see here let's try out the
new the new smg
and then uh what else did i want to do
oh
that i i got a new uh execution but i
wanted to show you guys mine mine's
funny
how do i even go to show the execution
i don't remember anymore oh well it
doesn't matter
my execution is uh gestures maybe no
um my execution is uh you kick the bad
guy in the balls and he's like
so i've kept that one from like the
moment i got it
okay guys let's throw on is there double
xp going on right now
there is so i'm gonna let it run
let's see here i unlock hate these
little green dots so i'm always trying
to
get rid of them so excuse me for one
second
what is this i thought there were
cigarettes that's not cool
what else did i unlock
i like in modern warfare we can just
press l3 and every green thing goes away
okay got the new smg
i'll keep toxic growth on let's go for a
gang
try again
thank you guys for being here and
chatting up
talking me up so nicely go to operators
okay before
it's all packed review
where personalize
no ah chat told me at the last second
like
to see my um
you know what's it called my executions
i thought
um maybe not i
i really don't remember i might be in
because you can't execute in zombies is
it really even here
hold on
random filter i don't i only have one
filter for for rebus here
my fellow nicaraguan lady let's see
what's all packed personalized yeah
forget it okay
i've i've put this off long enough let's
go mallard der toten
the new berlin map attempt number two
playing solo cold war is a must i feel
like the public servers are a bit rough
it's happened before the last stream i
was uh streaming with aaron
sampson and uh jake decker and we were
cross console it's it's kind of tough to
do live you know i don't ever want to
slow down the stream for any reason
howdy rate an objective of 250 kills
uh executions handy dragon are only a
multiplayer but i thought you could
do that in the zombies
all right here's the new smg guys
very dark here hold on i got my
flashlight on
oh now it's so bright go
check out this other check out my taunts
you think you could take me
[Laughter]
so badass right okay the rate of fire is
good on this
yeah but i saw a video this morning like
this gun is broken so i'm excited to use
it before it gets patched
all right but i'm not gonna be shooting
many people stabby stabbed him
right in his butt
valentina has planned this for some time
after all she brought the end station
rails to omega
was not so much the lucky draw from the
archives we believed
she knew about end station the portal
the dark ether
her father had a mission to secure the
future of the reich
and now she plans to complete it she
must fail
requiem you will see to it restore power
to the district first
okay i kept it quiet there for those who
are just joining and are interested at
all in the story
uh kravchenko has you and your team
pretty much
working for him because he's captured
raptor one your pilot
like you don't work for me and do what i
tell you stop
valentina uh then i'm gonna kill raptor
one
so we're working for kremchenko at the
moment
die zombie
[Applause]
whoa i mean
okay i'm gonna go to this side this side
has
a quick revive machine this has stamina
up
the power's off anyway i can't buy
anything
raccoon says for me i'm just dropping
frames and i can't get into a match
without
two host swaps oh man it sucks when you
actually want to you know
with other people and you can't
sorry i hope it works out it will you
know the
day one servers are always kind of mess
okay i need a little more there we go
the box is here you have better luck
getting a wonder weapon
in the early half of uh obvious match
that's for sure as soon as you start
doing objectives i swear the percentage
just drops to
nothing in my experience at least
okay now do i have enough
i mean good gun
there's always got to be at least one
russian in every call of duty zombies
is that true yeah let's see here
god i'm making a video right now for
game spot that's about like what makes
zombies so great
and uh there are so many zombies maps i
mean you guys know
it's been around since world at war
and there's a lot of things that make
zombies great but our video is like you
know top seven things
and i've been capping old zombies
footage and
having fun with all the on these maps
their trip
this gun isn't that powerful
unfortunately
i mean i knew it wouldn't be it's it's
it says oh the rate of fire is like the
best thing on it but
i'm going to need to pump up the damage
quickly
on this thing
die so is the map worth downloading the
game again that's a tough call
um if you look if you like zombies
um i keep i kind of keep black ops
around for the zombies at this point
personally i i rarely play multiplayer
anymore
um so i'm kinda i'm playing nothing but
zombies so if you're a fan of zombies
maybe consider downloading it because
a re-downloading it because if you've
bought the game this dlc
this map is free
but you know it's a hard ask for your
hard drive oh
you know what this thing pack a punch is
great in outbreak
but i'm not gonna do that right now
i love outbreak though
uh kino daretone yeah that's one of the
best for sure i was playing that to
capture footage for the video
uh yesterday and i was like man it's
hard to put this down he knows such a
great layout and um
pack of punching your weapon is easy as
pie
just kind of you know turn on the power
and hit like link the pad once you're
i thought there were like way more
people coming gotta use this uh
i always forget what it's called or
something like that
all right let's get the power on have
talk here
okay then i miss klaus already guys he's
not here but
um we got him going last match klaus the
helpful robot
and i miss him he's my bud best boy
yeah okay that's a good point angry
raccoon says i love outbreak but they
don't like
zombify the maps enough because yeah
they're reused maps from um
remember what's there
oh crap that's how i get the fuse
well he hit the pole i'm the door
getting
his head on
okay i'm getting
there
okay i'm gonna keep this guy around
while i try to get the power back on
oh check it out the death train
[Music]
that gets me every time i'm on instagram
after surviving so much getting hit by a
train
there's lousy mule kick
i'm the lousy one for incorrectly using
it oh my god it got me
killed last time
the train is awesome it's so fun i
haven't been caught in between the
trains yet like on the
you know the commercial for this map
uh you can get stuck in between them
but thank goodness i haven't i'm playing
solo i didn't have time for that
this gun is not the business right now i
need to power it up
i need to get rid of it to be honest
can we load this thing
okay well that was helpful although make
more money by not using a nuke
did they drop anything before i go on
nope okay great
yeah it seems like the ghost train from
warzone
yeah that was fun
oh geez i'll take that
great i can get the power back on
so much blood everywhere
let's try this find the end station
okay now the power's on i'm gonna get
some perks
and um try to get like the wonder weapon
i got klaus last time but i really would
like wonder weapon
i haven't got it yet and you know if we
find bits of the easter egg that's great
i'm not really
as you can tell by this point i'm not
really on the hunt for the big mystery
yet but
you know i would like help with that
actually
um you know on a later date
right now people are still trying to
discover i think the easter egg just
launched it
you know one hour ago okay
juggernog is in this room great i don't
have enough
damn what's that
these things dude they're like they're
kind of uh
dark ether canister things away with you
so yeah earlier we were saying that this
map reminds us of
the town area from transit
because you know the four corners here
and yeah i got that right away
i haven't even done this part yet
oh well i want perks first whoa swinging
a miss
i just stabbed one until level 10 that's
when the knife stops working
i don't know i should be leveling up
this gun so
guys's favorite gun to use in cold war
are uh zombies i should say
i know is i go back and forth i don't
think i have a favorite i'm like
whatever
i try out whatever is like trending you
know like m16
has been my favorite lately great for
high rounds
you know i just try to level everything
up
except snipers
glad i got the extended magazine on the
stock
version of this gun the ots is supposed
to be really small oh i have enough for
juggernaut juggernaut excuse me
oh yeah
made with real eggs
can i level this up yet do i have enough
it's called salvo
level one dies
hey watch it i do level two
good lord okay now i'm gonna go to the
other side
and see if i can get the hack-a-punch
machine going
what we need oh no this is better than
flashbangs
um yeah i need to go underground and
around
around town ouch
all right the doctor himself
in chat dr toffin 115
says i like this map
oh richtofen you guys see the rumors
that like
the main villain of this nap you know
valentino that commander lady
like is this eddie richtofen
i don't know dude i don't know why
people are saying that but there might
be some truth to that i have no idea
what's going on
she seems pretty evil but
i don't know they're definitely going to
try to bleed in the
old story i'm sure somehow they kind of
already are
okay so
these dudes don't want anything to do
with me
this guy controls them
johnny johnny in the chat what up cuz
wow
that little gun does not work well for
this guy who's already pretty weak
this guy is not that powerful
there we go
they gave me that advice like after i
killed them it's so stupid they're like
i think you should focus on
that guy he looks like trouble
okay i'm gonna kill these dudes trying
to make enough money to
pack and punch my gun let's use this i
still have this
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] i didn't mean to do that
more money when you don't nuke things oh
well
at least i can maybe i can do brain rot
first
yeah there we go
okay this map is cool man it's
definitely
a spooky vibe can i upgrade this yet
armor yeah now this thing will
probably be worth the damn this lousy
little gun i wanted to like this gun
but let's see
okay i also i would love deadshot that
great so i can get those head shots
your infection stops here yo
i swear these brain rot zombies run
faster
cool the turrets going off
die
okay i can't wait to unlock klaus for
those of you who are
tuned in recently uh klaus is the little
helper robot
we need to build him or we need to uh
reassemble him and then he'll help us
out
damn almost enough okay
i'm gonna check these little piles of
stuff can't be seen by that light
these little piles give you stuff one of
them even gives you a part to like the
easter egg not the easter egg
it helps you with klaus the robot
yeah i'm playing for my ps5 oh shoot i
hate that
thank you no no no i don't have enough
himself go to hell
i get him oh no he's on fire
i gotta hit his head i gotta get his
head stupid little head
oh
dude enough
there we go for goodness sake
now it's called the die breaker
see if it's any more powerful
you better be i just pack and punch it
for 5 000 bucks
why would they give me a double points
dude after i killed it
for the last guy
the gaming dragon dropping some classic
zombies knowledge in the chat
oh yeah there's always been there's been
a story to zombies from uh
well that war at first there wasn't
okay i'm gonna get out of here actually
uh i pack punched my gun i got brain rot
good
because requiem ever encountered the
problem it didn't try to destroy
shut up all these dudes dudes talk [ __ ]
at me
like you americans
there we go not so scary now double
points
oh you again
got him
okay so i still need some perks and i
still
want to try for the weapon i want my
hands on the wonder weapon
where's the box over there okay perks
first i need deadshot daiquiri if this
gun is gonna get me through
any more stages of any more rounds of
zombies i'm gonna need um
to not die and i'm gonna need
all for nothing look no one's here
anymore well there were something else
you mean like something else like that's
a hell of a game or like that's a
different story because
i don't want to mix what you're saying
up i'm not buying that
you'll kick screwed me up last time
well now i'll never forget how to use
properly
used mule kick i
used it before but it wasn't always my
favorite part back in the day
what am i doing oh yeah let's see here i
would like
to uh find the box and get deadshot
daiquiri
that shaking scared the [ __ ] out of me
the first time but it's actually just
the um
the train when did this drop
neil just dropped this morning i'm sorry
technically last night
um but the easter egg for this map
became unlocked
this morning at 10 am um
i think down here is where i can find
deadshot daiquiri and i have enough
money
but another 15 minutes or so here guys
and then um
we'll call it a wrap you guys can go
this is available yeah
this is available
there's a gate gate that has
i always forget where deadshot daiquiri
is and there's no map
except for my mini map
it's this one
graffiti okay i was there earlier i
don't need to open that door
there it is oh goodness oh do i have
enough i think it's 40
35 okay great
check it out classic oh great okay
now i got all my comfort perks and play
for a little longer try the box a few
call it a day where's the box
it might be underground i hate that the
light isn't so helpful nowadays
i got the power on i could also
i don't have that much time but um i was
gonna try to maybe get the robot back up
and running too
oh
but i need his hands and i need a
battery
i should have the battery by now no i
have two fuses that's it
okay i'm back here again
no holy crap
uh it is free in-game dlc this is the
newest
zombies map it's here to stay
the box in the shop
up here body drop
drop
yeah it's dlc
oh of course the box is always up here
dude every time i'm like looking for the
box
just always in this very corner
shut up
ksp i mean
it's not bad people weren't loving this
gun for a while it's the first
submachine gun i got gold because i
wanted to get it over with it
because i don't like three run bursts
anyway i don't love the ksp let's try
again
come on dude money money
have i do have a quick revive that's
good whatever speed this along i'll just
drop keep it on the ground there get
that on the ground
oh okay
why not i don't like the new laugh very
much because it actually sounds like a
child is like making fun of me before it
was like
a kid is laughing out of joy now it's
like
you're an idiot
i don't enjoy that because i really feel
like one after losing the box
you do get stuck
yeah i'm making it
look at that another two when there's
like two zombies around they give me
double points
there we go might as well take advantage
of double points
hmm okay i'll keep my monkey bunk
oh no angry raccoon died because he had
the base gun or his words he got his
cheeks clapped
where's the new box oh i was like in the
area
what the hell um oh it might be
underground
what i left stuff here oh speed cola
okay the box is definitely underground
hey better not nice i brain rotted this
pool
box box box where
i'm just going to circle this is over
for you
this is where you get the helper robot's
hands klaus's hands
this here but um i'm looking for the box
there it is
the e-tool give me a break
oh don't don't kill me i said give me a
break
no nuke i'll take it
okay
what i'm looking for oh simple and
effective
it's gonna leave all these on the ground
you will i'll take that
no why do they oh the dmr
box loves to give you the dmr
what another one of these smg my weapon
of choice
two how many craig sixes are they gonna
give me
foxy's baby extraction available
now i don't have enough money for
another try well
six which one has higher damage
this did okay well
i guess i can do a big loop around this
for the last few minutes here and try to
get the wonder weapon
but if not i'll die in a big blaze of
glory so you guys can watch that too
i have enough money i'll go around going
around
one less motorbike one less
whoa i need a break
rpg really dude
whoa what the
is this entirely almost die
yeah i know i could see that but i don't
want this gun so i'm just wasting its
bullets
oh fire sale perfect all right get rid
of this go go go go go go 10 bucks
last shot another i get [ __ ] done with
an assault rifle
oh my goodness well
might as well just uh see here
do it there we go oh the expo windows
closed i was gonna say
in my last few minutes here before we
shut it down maybe i could expel
probably just gonna have to die
i miss the ray guns i feel like i never
get it very much in um
cold war and regular round-based zombies
maps
i get in an outbreak kind of a lot which
is great
i can't believe i missed this the x-fil
window
i'm going in circles here
oh crap
i leave i left my other weapon on the
ground whatever it wasn't that great
loud and brown
let's see oh i can keep trying the box
for the last few minutes here
yeah ray gun percentage incredibly low
i'm happy to see it
i just wanted the new one so i can show
you guys for stream and now that i'm at
level
18 round 18 i doubt i'm gonna get it
dude
stupid funny
oh i haven't opened this yet i'm gonna
die
see ya okay
scratch some skills scratch those
success
let's see well i can't upgrade that i
don't want to upgrade this piece of crap
i'm just going to rock it with the ray
gun until party's over
is it so why is it extra oh because the
box just moved
bang okay come on dead shot didn't work
that well that time
dropped something
okay y'all are in my way
oh it's maximum perfect
well let's get an overhead view of
berlin here check it out
i mean i will see another x fill but i
was going to say we make sure to save it
here's a view of berlin
there's the wall
it's pretty pretty big map um
underground is like and you can go on
the rooftops too a lot of
verticality that's what they love they
love to say and it's true this map
[ __ ] this map has got a lot of it
swordfish it's their call sign
oh crap that one's dead
another fire sale this game is playing
me
where's the nearest box
there's a nearest box come on
really there's no box down here are you
serious dog
well the fire sale is almost over what a
waste
there's one
by the way i think my chopper gunner's
gonna like respawn which is cool
okay there's uh like what is that
the box duh wow do i actually have some
breathing room here
like it's hard to look at chat
uh of course it is it's zombies mode
yeah i ran right past one of course i'm
sure i did
[Applause]
i know uh wow that's funny that's just
sitting there i will
use sun's rc car needs new ones
and i cannot be bothered to go to store
this guy thinks he's so
fun i miss my team
miss weaver cool it's blue
or like light blue normally uh
pack a punching at once it's like
it's like green blue than pink but this
is like a new light blue i like it
all right just gonna see how much longer
i can survive here
all the wrap i don't think i'll be able
to get the wonder weapon
like i only have 100 bucks well actually
now i have 600.
i wonder if i can make it to the next
x-fill moment
i wonder how many rounds that takes like
another 10 rounds but
there we go put this stupid gun to use
the disciple that's funny
[Applause]
just spraying like rambo baby
you're still alive another one showed up
bring your dumb face nice
i think i accidentally minimized yeah
there we go am i doing the easter egg um
there was no rush to this this stream
was actually coming to a to an end here
soon
and um if i found parts of the easter
egg i was going to do it
but um this was more just like a you
know kickback stream to see
just check out the new map it just
happened to go live at 10 o'clock when
the easter egg launched
um yeah i don't have a guide or anything
like um
i and you know i wouldn't i would rather
get help if i'm gonna do the easter egg
but i'm just going solo right now
why did i reload give me that
these things are i don't like the dogs i
like these things better but they're
scary sounding
is the ray gun on marijuana or is the
cerberus the only wonder weapon
oh if you're angry raccoon if you're
watching um
i mean i have the ray gun right now it's
not i think you can get any wonder
weapon from the box
but cerberus is the new one that i don't
have
in fact i got six thousand bucks maybe i
should try one more time
maybe but i feel like i'm not gonna get
the
from the box like there's another way to
get it um but i need brain rot and i
gave away my gun with brain rot
i could pack a punch this gun but i'm
just you know
i'll be finishing up here in a minute
i was hoping for another x-fil option
that would be a great way to just
end this
high casualty or maybe i'll just die
like a regular
sir
next in the chat says math is all right
well welcome to this room i'm glad you
decided to watch anyway
um i'm sure it'll be fun once we all
figure out the easter egg you know i
love
something to accomplish in a zombies map
[ __ ] um we'll see there you go the
easter egg just launched an hour ago
get it going
i don't want my x-fil
already got the money there this is kind
of a this looks small but it's not a bad
spot to
kind of post up who's screaming
where's that here we go i will circle
back
i am glad you did not upset me
did i i really have an ex-fill window
all right that's it
i can't jump off
boy can't do two things at once can i
this is where you get the arms for the
robot they're over that dude's neck
right now
hey ben welcome to the chat about to
wrap things up here
um but if you're interested to watch
this it's going to be a
video on demand a little later today oh
my god
why did i stab well
wow that reload is so slow i forgot
i need
hard to uh small area to be fighting in
i shouldn't have
well i can always leave but
pretty challenging look at that
he's dead
there we go and this time i lost
deadshot daiquiri so i might be toast
for reals
away with you
classic ring
yeah i don't even know the i'm just
thinking to myself i don't even know the
first step of the easter egg
um that's you a million bucks like
the guide is already out on how to do it
maybe not a million bucks but you know
it's been an hour and treyarch
encourages it they're like
have fun you guys like who's gonna be
first and i'm like it's never me
just a casual a filthy casual
okay miss that shot
i got slapped around well
good as time as any um this map is
available
for free it's free dlc if you guys want
to check it out for yourselves
the easter egg is live so you can
probably do uh
you probably look into that and see i
definitely want to do the easter egg but
you know it's only been an hour so
there's no way i was going to start that
now
over here ta-da
great well thank you guys thank you guys
so much for tuning in nice little chill
stream just trying to
explore the new map and try some things
out um
but have fun if you're ready if you're
going to download it yourself
and uh tune in next time when we figure
out c
there's a stream for path of exile
coming up a little later today so tune
in for that
and we've got a lot of other call of
duty videos on our channel if you want
to check it out i will be putting out a
why zombies is so great video in the
next week
so look out for that until then i'll see
you guys next time
bye
you